in this lesson we're going to talk about
special right triangles so there's two
special right triangles you want to
familiarize yourself with and that's the
45-45-90
as well as the 30-60-90 so these are the
ratios that you want to memorize in a
45-45-90 triangle the two legs are the
two sides that make up the right angle
those are going to be the same because
this is an isosceles triangle but the
hypotenuse that's going to be
the leg times the square root of 2. so
square root of 2 is about 1.4 so the
hypotenuse is going to be the longer
side and it's going to be square root of
2 times
longer and if they give you the
hypotenuse what you would do is you
would then divide by the square root of
2 to get back to the to the leg or the
side and these are both going to be the
same
so the 45 45 90 there's not as much to
remember the 30 60 90 though what you
want to remember is that the side across
from the 30 degree angle that's going to
be the short leg that leg we call x the
one across from the 60 degree angle
that's the medium length side and that's
going to be x times the square root of 3
and then the longest side is across from
the height the right angle that's the
hypotenuse that's 2x
so essentially what you want to remember
is that if you have this side you just
have to double it to get the hypotenuse
or if you have the hypotenuse just
divide it by two to get back to the
short leg and then if you have the short
leg you can multiply by square root of
three to get the longer leg or divide by
square root of three to get the shorter
leg so let's go through some examples so
you can see how this works so let's do
the 45 45 90 ones first
so if both of these are five okay that
tells you that this is isosceles which
means that these are the same and these
are both going to be the same so this is
a 45 45 90 triangle
so we know this is five so that means
that x must be five times the square
root of two easy right okay now this
one's a little bit more challenging we
know that these sides are congruent we
can see that this is going to be a
45-45-90 triangle because all the angles
have to add up to 180 right
but to get from this hypotenuse to the
leg we actually have to do the opposite
we have to divide by the square root of
2. you don't want the square root in the
denominator so you rationalize by
multiplying by square root of 2 over
square root of 2. so that's going to
give you 10 square root of 2 square root
of 2 times square root of 2 is square
root of 4 which is 2 and the 10 and the
2 you can reduce that gives you 5 square
root of 2. so that would be the length
of this side as well as this side
okay now going over to the 30 60 90
triangle
that's this one here here they're giving
us the short leg so this is pretty easy
all we have to do is multiply by the
square root of 3
to get the longer leg and then double to
get the hypotenuse so that's going to be
8.
in this example here you can see it's a
30-60-90 triangle they're giving us the
hypotenuse we have to divide by two so
that's going to be six for the short leg
and then once we know the short leg we
can multiply by the square root of three
to get the longer leg so six square root
of three
and then the last example this is
probably the toughest example in a
30-60-90 triangle they're giving you the
longer leg that's the x squared of 3
side we want to divide by the square
root of 3 to get the shorter leg and
then we can double it to get the
hypotenuse so let's do that so 9 divided
by square root of 3 we don't want the
square root of 3 in the denominator so
we're going to rationalize by
multiplying by square root of 3 over
square root of 3. so that gives us 9
square root of 3
over 3.
9 divided by 3 is 3 so that's 3 square
root of 3. so that's the shorter leg
right here and then if we double it by
multiplying by 2 we get 6 square root of
3 is the hypotenuse okay now let's do a
more
typical example of what you may see
on the a-c-t
so for example here they give us this
45-45-90 combined with a 30-60-90
triangle making a little bit more
challenging and we're trying to find out
this length here y so go ahead and pause
the video see if you can solve this on
your own we'll go through it together
so what i would do here is um we know
that this is a 45 45 90. so if this is 3
this is also going to be 3 and then the
hypotenuse here is going to be 3 square
root of 2 okay
but now they're giving us the longer leg
in this 30-60-90 triangle so to get to
the shorter leg over here we actually
have to divide by the square root of 3.
we don't want that square root of 3 in
the denominator so i'm going to
rationalize so that gives us 3 square
root of 6 over 3 okay and you can see
the 3s are canceling so this is just
going to be square root of 6.
now to get the hypotenuse all we have to
do now is double
so that's going to be 2 times the square
root of 6
and
that's the length of the of the
hypotenuse so the 3690 triangle and
that's what we're solving for so you got
it so definitely something important to
know when you're preparing for the act
are these two special right triangles
memorize the ratios and if you need to
review this lesson i'll see you in the
next lesson